it's just a mother of all rocks but if
you use my superhuman strength I get
this baby up there should be he'll be
there hang on
Jeff and I team up it's taking all our
strength to lift this rock but it pays
off
we got one oh man this is my first
hellbender oh man that is incredible
look how fleshy these things are look at
all these folds of skin they use these
folds of skin I mean to take in oxygen
mm-hmm
increased surface area and more I bet
those things just flutter in the
currents just sit there and they'll just
wave back and forth and they have lungs
but they don't really use their lungs
for breathing
not very often it's just all through
their skin or through the lining of
their throat all through the skin
especially down this line right here
that's the hellbender skirt and it's all
gooey flesh in the skin under these
folds and along its body legs and in the
lining of its mouth are thousands of
capillaries that pull oxygen from the
water this breathing network is so
efficient that the hellbender never
leaves the water it uses its lungs not
to breathe but to stay buoyant
in fact hellbenders can live even if
their lungs are surgically removed they
look ugly to you that is beautiful to me
my first hellbender too curious why in
the world the story is in the
Appalachians when people first saw this
animal they're kind of swimming in the
river like I'm their bodies are bent
uh-huh and they look like they belong
and the infernal regions of hell but I
gotta admit I love that name hellbender
I may name my next child held in the
hellbender bar it's got a nice sound to
right
Jeff's brought his lab to the field he's
been tracking hellbenders for years and
lately he's finding them with open sores
mutilated limbs and even missing bones
what's killing them is still a mystery
but the culprit could be pollution like
all amphibians salamanders are
especially vulnerable to pollutants
because they're thin permeable skin
absorbs toxins easily it makes it an
early alarm system signaling that
something's wrong with the environment
luckily this one's still healthy and can
be returned to the river
but not before I perform to taste death
mr. hellbender for some reason I'm a
little reluctant to put the tongue on
the hellbender but in the name of
science I guess that's something I need
to do so oh that's bad man oh man I'm
not doing that again
that is bad that's some toxic stuff
there whoo man I can't even think of
anything to relate it to that's that may
be the most foul taste I've ever
experienced when it comes to noxious
slime the hellbenders gotta be king